horrendous graphical issues hamstrung
frame rates and maddening controls are
just a few things you'll probably be
hearing a lot of this episode since
cheer - the number of players who've
been putting up with bonfire and
lighting issues in Dark Souls 3 on PC
I've decided to talk about five PC ports
that might actually be worse
first up in what is surely one of the
most broken ports ever to grace the PC
we have saints row to this one sometimes
run at 15 frames per second even if you
turned your graphics settings all the
way down the controls were in nightmare
and if you could get a handle on them
you were still being plagued by constant
crashes there are also reports that the
game played like it was stuck on
fast-forward and actions would sometimes
not respond to the keys they were mapped
to it seems for three months this one
took to land on PC after its console
counterparts wasn't nearly long enough
Grand Theft Auto 4 doesn't just share
the open world and criminal inclinations
of Saints Row 2 it also arrived on PC
broken it's [ __ ] Grand Theft Auto floor
took almost eight months to arrive on PC
after its initial release on ps3 and
xbox360 PC gamers were so damn excited
to get this one and unfortunately it not
only required a super high-end system it
was peppered with bugs and framerate
issues many players were forced to lower
their resolutions to make the port run
soon after launch motors did their best
to do what the devs didn't all the
Rockstar did eventually patch things
themselves if you want to know what a
red flag looks like it's something along
the lines of a PC game ported from ps2
game which is itself ported from a
GameCube game yeah it's shocking that
after all of that the original Resident
Evil 4 on PC didn't turn out so great
the cutscenes looked awful and the game
had rendering issues missing lighting
effects made everything look green gray
and it had that crashing all the damn
time problem resi 4 on peace day was
also originally bloody impossible to
play without a gamepad my condolences to
those of you who tried with your
keyboard or hoped there would be any
kind of Mel support like many of the
games on this list fan-made patches have
solved the bulk of the ports issues but
they really shouldn't have had to
what with the fact that people paid
actual money for this thing Resident
Evil 4 is still a great game and if you
want to play it on PC
I'd recommend playing the 2014 HD
re-release which you can find
steam since it did a much better job of
bringing the classic game over
sometimes lightning actually does strike
twice
which is why on this episode inspired by
Dark Souls threes PC port I'm gonna talk
about Dark Souls prepare to die edition
this one particularly stings because
almost 100 thousand people signed a
petition asking for Dark Souls to come
to PC and what finally arrived was so
bad
unfortunately the focus seemed to be on
adding content and not optimizing the
game that already existed the port was
locked at a 720p resolution and 30
frames per second fine for the console
version but seriously inferior to the
resolution that most monitors run at it
also used the infamous games for Windows
Live DRM and featured nigh on useless
keyboard and mouse controls that aside
from being unresponsive put actions in
super hard-to-reach spots like on the
end button yeah go on and check your
keyboard it's actually that far away if
you did decide to plug your controller
in you may have also been treated to the
persistent issue of the mouse cursor
never disappearing off the screen super
annoying allocated modest have now fixed
up the game so you have them to thank if
you're happily playing it on PC now and
the game has since swapped out games for
Windows Live for Steamworks Dark Souls 2
& 3 third a lot better but have still
had their share of troubles Dark Souls 2
could run at a higher framerate but that
meant the game calculated and
implemented weapon degradation at a
punishingly accelerated pace and now in
Dark Souls 3 we have the bonfire crashes
finally and I'm sure you saw this one
coming is Batman Arkham Knight for PC a
game so bad that one of others actually
had to pull it off shelves Batman Arkham
Knight on PC could have been a totally
decent game but much like Assassin's
Creed unity or watchdogs there was just
no way to tell underneath all the
technical bugs and crap graphics the
port was passed off to a different
studio who must have had quite a bit of
trouble as stuttering gameplay and hard
crashes ensued for unlucky players who
picked it up on piece
see the poet was capped at 30 frames per
second and required insanely high system
requirements and even if you did have
those it was still a far cry from
running smoothly WB pulled the game
almost immediately after launch began to
work on patches and started issuing
refunds even when Arkham Knight for PC
did finally return to sale players were
still reporting lingering technical
issues some things just weren't meant to
be I guess let me know Dani in that
comment section in which game you think
have the worst PC port and be sure to
let me know if there are any games that
I missed I will see you again soon